même la ministre le 8 avril dernier le
président la république a confirmé son
intention de réformer la formation des
hauts fonctionnaires qui passe notamment
par la suppression de l'école nationale
d'administration et la création d'un
institut du service public la réforme en
réalité qui est engagée dépasse celle
d'une école le gouvernement s'engage
dans une refonte plus large des
modalités d'accès aux fonctions
publiques en supprimant le statut de
corps de fonctionnaires pour favoriser
le statut ou les statuts plutôt
d'emplois c'est très fort mais préparez
annoncé de longue date puisque dell
avril 2019
il ya déjà deux ans le plan de la
république avait fait l'annoncé de sa
volonté de changement et avait par
ailleurs missionné monsieur frédéric
thiriez est pour conduire une réflexion
sur ce sujet dont les conclusions
réalité n'ont été connues qu'à la date
du mois de janvier dernier
fin 2020 pardon mais il semble que ce
qu'envisage aujourd'hui gouvernement est
bien au delà de ce qui avait été proposé
dans ce rapport quel qu'en soit le
contenu
la réforme de la fonction publique
implique à la fois une intervention
législative et une modification de
plusieurs textes à caractère
réglementaire
pour ce qui est des modifications
relevant de la loi le gouvernement a
reçu une habilitation à intervenir par
ordonnance en date n'est pas un parent
dans ce pardon par l'article 59 de la
loi de transformation de la fonction
publique du 6 août 2019 qui l'est c'est
très ouvert le champ de la réforme
puisque il autorisait le gouvernement
sur 3.1 organisé le rapprochement et
modifier le financement des
établissements publics et services qui
concourent à la formation des agents
publics pour améliorer la qualité du
service rendu aux agents et aux
employeurs publics 2 pour réformer les
modalités de recrutement des corps et
cadres d'emplois de catégorie a
afin de diversifier leurs profils
harmoniser leur formation initiale créer
un tronc commun d'enseignements et
développer leur formation continue afin
d'accroître leur culture commune
l'action publique pardon d'aménager leur
parcours de carrière en adaptant les
modes de sélection et en favorisant les
mobilités au sein de la foule
son public et vers le secteur privé de
renforcer la formation des agents
les moins qualifiés d âge en situation
de handicap ainsi que les agents les
plus exposées au risque d'usure
professionnelle afin de favoriser leur
évolution professionnelle
le délai d'habilitation expire ras le 7
juin prochain
l' ordonnance prise sur ce fondement
devait être adopté ce matin je crois en
conseil des ministres et vous deviez ne
l'a présentée mais son examen a été
reporté d'une semaine la ministre mais
nous vous remercions tout de même d'être
là cet après-midi et de venir devant la
commission pour nous exposer celle ci
peut être vous faire quelques
révélations que nous n'aurions pas
neutre et non pas cela possible je ne
sais pas en espérons en tous les cas je
voudrais en tout état de cause
dire que c'est réformes annoncées à la
fois passionne pour certains de façon
positive d'autres sont plus inquiets
et ont des interrogations c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous aurons au
moins sur deux plans s'agissant de la
formation initiale des hauts
fonctionnaires la création d'une
nouvelle école soulève certains quelques
scepticisme par rapport aux modèles et
na n a plus la plus value de réelle d'un
nouvel institut une question que je pose
au sens qu'il n'est pas personnel mais
je que je m'intègre de plusieurs
réflexions entendues mais le débat porte
surtout sur le statut futur de certains
fonctionnaires qui sèche de ceux qui
sont chargés de mission je lectionnaire
conseil d'état ou cour des comptes de
ceux qui assurent des fonctions
d'inspection inspections générales des
finances d'administration par exemple ou
qui sont les chefs de l'administration
déconcentrée de l'état dans les
départements les régions à savoir les
préfets les parcours de carrière ses
fonctionnaires doivent en effet
absolument présenter des garanties en
termes de compétences bien sûr et pour
certains d'entre eux d'indépendance pour
que certaines de ces fonctions qui sont
au coeur de notre état de droit puisse
s'exercer dans des conditions
satisfaisantes voilà même la miss ces
quelques propos introductif que je
voulais tenir avant de vous laisser la
parole tout en vous disant qu'à l'issue
de votre intervention portera la parole
madame di folco qui est notre rapporteur
pour avis des crédits de la fonction
publique
et puis naturellement à tous les
collègues qui souhaitent s'exprimer afin
que chacun puisse vous interroger sur
ce que vous allez nous dire merci je
vous donne la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un honneur pour moi de présenter
ici au sénat devant votre commission
l'ordonance qui porte donc réforme de
l'encadrement supérieur de l'état
c'est un honneur parce que ce texte 75
ans après celui du général de gaulle les
dons utiles debré fut le principal
artisan est un rendez-vous de l'état
avec son histoire et avec son avenir
c'est aussi un rendez vous au service
des français est au service de la
transformation de notre pays à ses
rendez vous je sais les hommes et les
femmes qui servent l'état de tout leur
coeur répondront présents comme ils
l'ont fait avec éclat et courage pendant
la crise sanitaire que nous traversons
en 1945 au sortir de la guerre
par delà les parties par delà les
corporatismes une ordonnance jetait les
bases d'un système administratif nouveau
et forget on s'en souvient non sans
résistance
une nouvelle génération de hauts
fonctionnaires formés aux enjeux du 20e
siècle le monde d'aujourd'hui n'est plus
le même les enjeux ont radicalement
changé
des bouleversements technologiques aux
chocs climatiques la france de 2020
terre n'est plus la même que celle de
elle a aussi entre temps connu la
décentralisation un mouvement de
déconcentration et la haute assemblée le
sait ici mieux que quiconque
parallèlement le système de gestion des
corps de recrutement de gestion des
carrières
c'est rigidifier s'éloignant donc de la
promesse initiale de 1945
alors pour revenir à cette promesse pour
la tenir pour 2021
il faut la mettre à jour profondément en
saisissant le moment et aussi le défi de
cette nouvelle crise
même si vous le savez nous n'avons pas
attendu cette crise vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président pour engager cette
réforme c'est une réforme je crois
profondément gaullienne profondément
républicaines et c'était et c'était un
engagement fort du président la
république pris dès 2017 devant les
français cet engagement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs il sera tenu
dans la continuité de nombreuses
réformes engagées depuis le début du
quinquennat et dont je suis la bonne
exécution au sein de ministres en aient
fait tant de gouvernement tende majorité
ont promis de mener ce chantier majeur
sont toujours avoir le courage ni la
volonté d'aller jusqu'au bout
pourquoi parce que d'abord ce n'est
jamais le bon moment parce qu'aussi
c'est une réforme réellement difficile
qui demande de décider dans l'intérêt
seul de la nation et c'est plus
difficile sans doute certainement mêmes
que celles qui ont consisté à dépouiller
l'état de ses forces vives à coup de
rabot budgétaire et qui ont beaucoup
affaibli notamment nos services
déconcentrés nos préfectures nos sous
préfecture ce gouvernement avec cette
majorité donc a le courage de faire face
à ces défis pour refonder la formation
et carrières des cadres de l'état du 21e
siècle sans rien renier de la promesse
de 1945 dans l'intérêt supérieur de
l'état et donc des français j'ai tenu
monsieur le président vous le savez à
venir devant le parlement pour présenter
avant l'adoption la semaine prochaine en
conseil des ministres pour présenter
cette ordonnance pour laquelle vous avez
habilité le gouvernement dans la loi de
transformation la fonction oblique de
je crois que loin des caricatures des
postures d'un certain angle de
détournement que certains complaisent se
complaisent à entretenir
je souhaite vraiment que nos débats
d'aujourd'hui permettent de rappeler le
sens
l'ambition de cette transformation que
nous engageons on peut bien sûr être en
désaccord avec cette réforme et on peut
d'ailleurs manifestement ne pas être
toujours cohérent avec les propositions
les positions prises par le passé
c'est d'ailleurs plusieurs fois
constatée dans les débats récents de la
part de certains ou d'autres mais
lorsque je lis ça et là que nous
supprimerions l'institution préfectorale
ou que nous serions sur le point
d'organiser un grand spoil system à
l'américaine je dois vous le dire très
solennellement les bras m'en tombent
parce que au débat d'idées manifestement
certains ont choisi plutôt la course à
l'outrance électorale et je crois que
c'est déplorable sur un sujet aussi
important
plus fondamentalement dans ce contexte
préélectoral
je crois qu'il faut dénoncer très
fermement toute tentative de
récupération notre haute fonction
publique à des fins politiciennes
ce serait un très grave danger pour
notre démocratie et je suis en tant que
ministre la fonction publique très
attaché à ce que les hommes et les
femmes qui servent notre pays le fassent
en ayant chevillée au corps les valeurs
du service public
je tiens d'abord en tant que mise la
fonction publique a salué l'engagement
le dévouement de tous les agents publics
et de tout nouveaux fonctionnaires en
particulier pendant cette crise
sanitaire
ils ont su faire face
nrj avec intelligence avec abnégation
aux exigences de sauver des vies
humaines d'assurer l'ordre public de
maintenir la continuité du service
public essentiel à nos concitoyens ils
ont comme jamais innover inventer sans
jamais donc renier ses valeurs
fondamentales que je citais la
continuité d'état l'égalité de
traitement de tous les usagers la
neutralité la laïcité
nos agents publics obtenus et grâce à
eux avec eux c'est l'état qui a tenu
mais au delà cette crise la plus grave
certainement que nous ayons connue
depuis le milieu du xxème siècle nous
devons nous rendre à l'évidence et les
représentants de la nation je crois le
savent et le constate au quotidien les
30 dernières années ont été marquées par
un affaiblissement de la perception de
l'état par nos concitoyens voir on peut
même parler d'une défiance grandissante
qui contribuent à nourrir les extrêmes
le constat est sans appel les français
veulent un état fort parce qu'ils
veulent être protégés et il attend des
services publics sur tout le territoire
parce qu'ils sont attachés à l'égalité
mais ils ne veulent plus de la
complexité caractérise bien trop souvent
l'action publique et à laquelle nous
nous sommes attaqués je sais à quel
point les préoccupations ici que je
nomme le scénar les partage en échange
il ya quelques jours quelques semaines
avec la délégation aux collectivités et
en particulier sa mission chargée la
simplification le mois dernier n'a fait
que confirmer à quel point cette
priorité était madame la présidente
partager je tiens donc à le dire ici
solennellement les hommes et les femmes
ne sont nullement en cause puisque ils
sont eux-mêmes souvent les premières
victimes d'un système qui crée de la
complexité et qui nourrit l'impuissance
est ce donc c'est donc fort de ce
constat que nous avons bâti cette
réforme que je vous présente aujourd'hui
parce que nous voulons refonder une
action publique qui correspondent au
siècle qui s'ouvre qui répondent aux
attentes fortes exprimées par nos
concitoyens
mes attentes de proximité d'humanité de
simplicité et d'efficacité
je voudrais donc brièvement vous
présenter les trois mesures
les trois idées qui bâtit cette réforme
d'abord l'enjeu c'est bien de renforcer
la confiance entre les citoyens et
l'état avec une haute fonction publique
qui soient davantage à l'image de la
réalité sociale et territoriale de notre
pays
c'est l'ambition du programme talents du
service public que le président de la
république a présenté à nantes en
février qui s'est concrétisée dans
lordonnance promulguée le 3 mars qui
bien sûr ne renie pas ni ne fait
l'impasse sur les insuffisances du
système scolaire auquel le gouvernement
s'est attaqué depuis 2017
mais ce programme a pour ambition de
faire en sorte que cette fonction
publique que nous aimons que nous
connaissons redeviennent l'ascenseur
social républicain qu'elle a été
concrètement ce programme act dès la
rentrée de 2021 la création partout sur
le territoire
dans 74 universités 2700 places au sein
donc de 74 classe préparatoire au grand
concours de la fonction publique pour
les jeunes boursiers et qui proposera ce
programme par ailleurs qu'à la rentrée
prochaine
35 places soit réservé à ses élèves
boursiers dans les différents concours
de la fonction publique dans le plein
respect et j'insiste des principes posés
par l'article 6 de la déclaration du
droit des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen n'en déplaise à certains nous
l'aurions nous aurions pu décider
d'attendre que les mesures prises dès
l'école maternelle primaire où le
collège fasse son plein effet dans 10 ou
20 ans mais il nous a semblé que sur
l'égalité des chances
nous n'avions pas le droit d'attendre et
qu'il fallait donc agir maintenant
deuxième axe de la réforme que je porte
sous l'autorité du président la
république et du premier ministre
c'est celui d'assurer aux cadres
supérieurs de l'état une formation et
une carrière qui soit en adéquation avec
les besoins de l'action publique au 21e
siècle et avec les aspirations des
jeunes générations qui sinon se
détourneront plus encore de la fonction
publique une formation initiale
fusse-t-elle de qualité
on le voit ne saurait suffire à
appréhender accompagner ces changements
de même une formation qui se limiterait
à reproduire des schémas administratif
et prouver ou à reproduire les
enseignements reçus entièrement ne
serait également être satisfaisante
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
créons l'institut national du service
public qui verra donc le jour le 1er
janvier 2022 à strasbourg et qui
deviendra le principal aux opérateurs de
formation de l'encadrement supérieur
formation initiale formation continue
évidemment des administrateurs de l'état
avec une formation beaucoup plus ouverte
sur le monde académique et en faisant
place à l'esprit
tiko sens de l'innovation sans bien sûr
renier les fondamentaux de notre
république
mais également en institut qui formera
plus généralement l'ensemble des cadres
supérieurs de l'état mais aussi de la
fonction publique territoriale et
hospitalière parce qu'à un commissaire
de police un directeur d'hôpital en in
administrateurs des états ont beaucoup à
apprendre ensemble et donc lille en
espèces sera chargé d'animer
d'approfondir de faire vivre un tronc
commun de formation communs donc à 14
écoles du service public pour cette
formation initiale et dans les 14 écoles
de service public
on retrouve les cinq écoles
d'application de l'école polytechnique
donc également au delà de la force
publique territoriale hospitalière
les corps techniques au delà la
formation il s'agit aussi de renforcer
l'évaluation des cadres supérieurs de
les accompagner tout au long de leur
carrière en favorisant la mobilité et
l'acquisition de compétences dans des
filières métiers des métiers reconnus
comme thème mobilité respiration
accompagnement sont désormais les
maîtres mots de la carrière des hauts
fonctionnaires
j'en ai pleinement conscience c'est
d'abord évidemment un défi culturel
important car le constat aujourd'hui est
clair trop peu de nos dirigeants ont pu
bénéficier d'un vrai parcours de
carrière ou ont pu se voir offrir des
formations adaptées à leurs aspirations
c'est dommageable évidemment à l'action
publique
c'est également dommageable aux cadres
de l'état et ce sera le rôle de la
nouvelle délégation interministérielle à
l'encadrement supérieur de l'état d'y
remédier
troisième et donc dernière idée que vous
les partager c'est celui de mettre fin
aux voies toutes tracées qui se dessine
sur la base d'un rang de classement a
sorti d'une école et qui génère son lot
d'injustices cette frustration à
l'averse je crois que nous pouvons nous
fixer un objectif simple mettre les
bonnes compétences aux bons endroits et
notamment plus proche des besoins de nos
concitoyens sur le terrain dans les
territoires à la sortie d un sp le
classement de sortie perdurera mais
permettra de choisir son premier poste
il constitue ce classement en gage de
transparence et d'équité mais sa portée
sera évidemment très réduite par rapport
à ce que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
car tous les élèves sortants lienne sp
seront inclus et rejoindront donc le
corps des administrateurs de l'état
ils n'auront plus accès au 15 place pour
que les grands corps
leur réserver et devront tous avoir une
première expérience opérationnelle avant
de juger de contrôler ou d'inspecter
nous aurions pu comme certains le
préconisent dans d'autres familles
politiques mettre fin au statut et
recruter uniquement sur contrat nous
n'avons pas voulu céder à cette facilité
car nous sommes attachés à ce statut qui
bien sûr emportent des droits mais
également des obligations et nous avons
choisi de créer le corps des amis sens
de l'état qui pourra donc constitué dès
demain le principal corps de
l'encadrement supérieur
cela permettra de passer d'une logique
de corps à une logique de métiers de
compétences au service des besoins
d'état et en libérant les cadres
supérieurs les femmes notamment de
beaucoup de schémas prédéterminée et
donc de carcans administratifs ses
besoins de l'état ils sont aujourd'hui
sur le terrain au plus près des français
ils sont allés fonctions opérationnelles
et la réforme permettra de mieux les
satisfaire en faisant du passage par de
telles fonctions nous pas un frein un
carrière mais au contraire un passage
obligé est valorisée en conclusion cette
réforme dames et messieurs les sénateurs
n'est donc certainement pas comme
certains voudraient laisser entend
celles de la déconstruction de l'état il
s'agit bien d'une refondation nous
voulons continuer à attirer les
nouvelles générations vers services de
l'état nous voulons redonner à la
fonction publique son caractère
réellement méritocratique ce sont
évidemment des défis qui impose de
profonds changements qu'il était urgent
d'entreprendre plus qu'une
transformation c'est donc bien un
changement culturel profond qu'il
convient d'opérer et que nous engageons
avec cette réforme c'est la condition
indispensable d'un état qui se rend plus
proche plus humain plus efficace comme
les français l'appellent de leurs voeux
car plus que jamais je crois que la
france et les français ont besoin de
l'état et l'état a besoin de sa fonction
publique de ces cartes supérieures
c'est le défi que nous devons relever
avec le président de république et le
premier ministre et je me tiens
évidemment monsieur le président
désormais à votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions
merci la ministre
cette présentation propose d'être un
homme dit folco de les questions et puis
les collègues qui souhaitent intervenir
ce signal de façon à ce qu'on puisse
lors des jeux puis lors de la parole
rapidement
madame di folco merci monsieur le
président merci madame la ministre pour
cette présentation
alors plusieurs questions la première
finalement presque la plus évidente
le gouvernement a eu une habilitation a
ordonné à produire une ordonnance
il faut que celle-ci soit ratifié pensez
vous qu'elle puisse être ratifié de
façon rapide
c'est compte tenu de l'importance de la
réforme et de saison je pense
indispensable que le parlement puisse
l'examiner et en tout état de cause ce
serait bien que ce soit fait avant la la
mise en oeuvre des premières mesures et
j'entends que les premières mesures
s'appliquent à la rentrée de 2021
première question deuxième question
monsieur le président l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure monsieur thiriez avait été
missionnée pour rendre un rapport qui
enfin produire un rapport qui a été
rendu il ya un an
quelle mesure de ce rapport avez-vous
retenu dans la réforme
troisième question cette réforme est
présentée par certains comme le début de
la fin de l'administration à la
française qui est fondée sur la carrière
au profit d'une administration ouverte
faut-il concevoir votre projet comme une
volonté de remise en cause du modèle à
la française qui est sans doute un
parfait mais qui peut certainement faire
l'objet d'ajustements ou d'une plus
grande diversité de profils et qui est
incontestablement fait ses preuves
quatrième question il résulte de cette
réforme une forte inquiétude sur la
disparition de certains corps vous êtes
élevé contre tout à l'heure mais on
entend bien parler de la suppression du
corps préfecture préfectorale par
exemple qu'en est il qu'est ce qui va
changer
moi j'entends tout plein de choses
j'entends beaucoup de personnes qui
s'élèvent contre st mais on connaît la
relation mère préfet on en parle tous
depuis notamment la gestion de la crise
c'est les bonnes relations que nous
avons sur le terrain les élus locaux
avec le préfet on a un petit peu peur
que le préfet disparaissent mais il va
pas disparaître forcément il y aura
quand même le représentant de l'état
mais quelle sera la différence entre le
préfet actuel est le nouveau
fonctionnaire qui représentera l'état
sur le terrain et peut-être dernière
question cette réforme entend
revaloriser des parcours professionnels
qui ne dépendrait plus vous dépendrez
moins d appartenance à un corps de
fonctionnaires intégré pour l'essentiel
dès la sortie de l'école comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
je comprends que ce soit ainsi qu'il
serait créé une délégation
interministérielle qui serait chargée de
piloter une véritable politique de
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
des compétences
alors sans nier l'intérêt de cette
démarche une telle délégation
aura-t-elle les moyens humains mais
aussi l'ascendance suffisant pour
dépasser cette logique actuelle de
cordes fonctionnaires et remplir son
objectif je vous remercie
merci à l'inventeur monsieur dany
wattebled
trois questions dont une dans chaque
sens de l'ena quelles mesures comptez
vous prendre pour combattre le phénomène
de pantouflage si répandue parmi les
anciens élèves de l'ena ou d'autres
encore comme l'inspection des finances
alors que l'état lourdement investi pour
leur formation pour les laisser passer
constamment du public ou privé en
laissant toutes considérations éthiques
deuxième question qui dépend pas
forcément ne voudra peut-être l'occasion
n'a pas là dans la loi cadre des as le
gouvernement envisage de renforcer la
réactivité des services administratifs
aux demandes des usagers ou tout le
moins à renforcer le principe de silence
vaut acceptation adopté en 2013 dont
l'application connaît tellement
d'exceptions que seuls 34% des démarches
sont régis par ce principe
enfin dernière question celle là est un
peu plus ça ne m'est arrivé cette
semaine mais c'est ce qu'on doit agir
pour contrer le pouvoir écrasant de
notre administration et de ses
différentes agences pour tous d'ici
privés ou publics
un exemple j'ai un maire cette semaine
ils ont récupéré une pierre qui datent
du 7e siècle une période pourrait
aiguiser les épées c'est un gros bloc
quand la vie dans un coin et s'était
classé bâtiment historique à 500 mètres
de là le maire a un projet pour faire
une école avec une cantine scolaire
il ya trois maisons à battre trois
maisons à battre qui sont des anciennes
mines tueur aucun intérêt et ne peuvent
pas parce que les bâtiments de france
ont décidé que c'était dans le périmètre
classé on peut pas comparer ça avec le
d'autres éléments notamment
donc j'étais un peu surpris et croyez
moi je vais pas rester là parce que je
trouve ça un peu un conséquent que
quelqu'un qui se permet on a
l'impression que c'est l'inversé les
l'udc est au service de la distraction
et non l inverse
et ça c'est un peu je sens bien que à ce
sujet là dans madame bachelot parce que
c'est un projet d'envergure qui
conditionne toute une orthèse colère et
ne peut pas en plus ce n'est même pas
pour conscience pour faire un parking
pour qu'on voit cette école et cette
cantine scolaire qu'en lui donnant cette
pierre qui est pas là qui dira cacher
derrière l'église qu'on ne voit pas
souvent un grand paquet de verre et qui
empêche de faire ça donc on voit que la
discrétion n'est pas service aux usagers
n'est pas service du citoyen c'est tout
l'inversé
merci de me répondre merci monsieur
philippe bas madame la ministre
merci de cet exposé introductif qui nous
a permis de constater que vous
considériez cette réforme comme
profondément gaullienne et républicaine
et vous n'avez pas manqué ensuite de
saluer le courage de ce gouvernement je
suppose que vous voulez dire votre
courage et celui du premier ministre et
de l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement
on n'est jamais mieux servi que par soi
même mais en ce qui me concerne je
m'interroge sur le caractère réellement
gaullien et république d'une réforme qui
remet en cause en réalité à la fois les
x du chef du gouvernement de la
république française en 1945 et ceux du
chef du gouvernement de la même
république en 58 et du président de la
république en 1959
vous voulez constituer un corps
d'administrateur interministériel ce
corps existe c'est le corps des
administrateurs civils et c'est même la
raison d'être de la création de l'ena
que d'avoir mis fin à des recrutements
spécifiques de chaque ministère de
rédacteurs qui en cite gravissait les
échelons pour atteindre des postes de
responsabilité je comprends qu'en
réalité ce n'est pas tant
l'interministérialité qui vous
intéressent que l'absorption par ce
corps interministériels d'un certain
nombre d'autres corps que justement le
général de gaulle n'avait pas souhaité
intégrer au corps des administrateurs
civils
je pense notamment au corps préfectoral
et je vois bien et je voudrais pas
tomber dans les caricatures que certains
se complaisent à entretenir je vous cite
qu' il ne s'agit pas de supprimer les
préfets la fonction de préfet mais
seulement leur statut mais justement la
question que je me pose c'est est-ce que
ce statut n'est pas nécessaire à
l'exercice de la fonction
autrement dit le statut des préfets
prévoit que une proportion suffisante de
préfets doivent être issus du corps des
sous préfets parce qu'on a pensé que la
fonction de préfet était un métier
évidemment d'autres que des sous préfets
peuvent être capable d'exercer ce métier
mais on a tout de même considéré qu'il y
avait une culture préfectoral il y avait
un apprentissage de la fonction de
préfet qui faisait que au fond
administrateurs et civils n'était pas
civil et préfet n'était pas complètement
interchangeables alors oui moi je fais
partie de ceux qui s'inquiètent au nom
du service de l'état de voir disparaître
des garanties qui organise la carrière
des membres du corps préfectoral et qui
font que au fond ces préfets sont un
trait d'union entre le gouvernement et
les responsables élus de la population
dans les territoires et qu' il est très
important y compris pour la
décentralisation qui appelle la présence
d' interlocuteur capable de s'engager le
calme mais qui est également important
pour l'autorité de l'état si malmenée
dans la période actuelle que les préfets
est à la fois des garanties et soient
soumis à des obligations comme
l'obligation d'impartialité qui nous
protège de
la diffusion d'un esprit courtisans dans
la fonction préfectorale alors je
voudrais que puisque votre présentation
cd cd c'est la loi du genre est resté
tout de même très générale que vous nous
indiquer quelles seront les garanties
applicables aux préfets et comment on
assurera le maintien d'un apprentissage
de ce métier dans le cadre que vous
voulez mettre en place et je complète ma
question
en quittant le corps préfectoral pour
parler des corps d'inspection parce que
je suis également inquiet de voir
disparaître un certain nombre de
garanties d'indépendance dont certaines
sont prétorienne qui protège les corps
d'inspection de l' influence ministériel
qui est propre à vouloir obtenir d'eux
plutôt des rapports qui leur sont
favorables que le contraire merci
monsieur questeur usmam gatel la prison
merci beaucoup mais je suis président
merci madame la ministre je profite de
votre venue ici pour vous rappeler la
question que je vous ai posé lors de
votre audition à la délégation qui
s'adressait c'est une question qui avait
été posée au premier ministre sur
l'évaluation qui avait été faite du
pouvoir réglementaire qui avaient été
données aux préfets
cette question étant reposer madame la
ministre je crois que chacun d'entre
nous partagent le constat qu'il est
indispensable de renforcer la confiance
de nos concitoyens dans l'état certes
vous évoquez un point qui est de dire
qu'il y aurait sans doute une attente de
nos concitoyens que l'administration
ressemble plus à ce qu'est la société
je partage votre rappel de l'intérêt de
l'ascenseur social mais la question que
je me pose des celles que vous vous êtes
certainement posée c'est la question de
l'efficacité de l'action publique nous
regagnerons la confiance de nos
concitoyens uniquement par l'efficacité
de l'action publique
et j'aurai enfin gilles 5 remarque
observations la première c'est avons
nous constaté une carence des préfets
moi je dirais qu'aujourd'hui au sortir
de la crise toutes les études qui ont
été faites les observations montrent que
les préfets ont plutôt étaient de grands
serviteurs de l'état
ils ont su gérer la crise de manière
localement d'une manière assez
remarquable sachant s'entourer de tous
les acteurs qui étaient nécessaires
sachant apprécier les situations il est
traité avec intelligence donc je
m'interroge sur ce point pour savoir si
nous le partageons offre une petite
exception peut-être qu'ils celle des
directeurs des jeux ne met pas du tout
en cause les personnes ni leur formation
je dis juste qu'il m'a semblé dans cette
crise sanitaire qu'il y avait une
inadéquation entre la formation et la
mission des directeurs des ars et celle
qu'ils ont dû réaliser une mission
beaucoup plus opérationnels pendant la
crise sans doute là avons nous un écart
entre les besoins et les réponses
apportées
l'autre point concerne il me semble
avant d'oeuvrer sur les solutions et des
propositions est ce que l'état lui même
a bien défini et afficher clairement ses
missions et ses exigences
je crois qu'on pourra décider de profil
ou de modification de recrutement quand
on aura un accord parfait sur quelle est
la mission de l'état quelles sont ses
compétences et comment l'état peut-il
servir l'action publique
ça c'est une vraie question on a vu
beaucoup d'observations sur un état qui
serait plutôt chasseurs un peu
compliquant la vie plutôt qu'un état
facilitateur donc il faut qu'on
redéfinisse à et c'est pour ça que je
crois c'est mon troisième point qu'il
s'agit avant tout d'un changement de
culture dans l'univers des politiques et
des dirigeants
c'est un souci de l'efficacité de
l'action publique construite sur le
principe de subsidiarité la conscience
pour les grands serviteurs de l'état et
pour tout gouvernement quel qu'il soit
que
étape vouloir mais ne pourra que s'il
travaille en étroite collaboration avec
les collectivités donc moi je n'ai pas
entendu beaucoup de choses sur ce point
quatrième point une expérience
d'administration ouverte a été fait
madame la ministre ait récemment avec le
plan de relance puisque le gouvernement
nous indiqué souhaiter créer des poches
de sous préfet à la relance très ouvert
avec des profils très différents sur des
profils qui ne venaient pas de
l'administration qui venait du privé
alors moi j'ai rien contre le changement
contre l'enrichissement des profils et
je pense pas qu'on doive opposé le
secteur privé du secteur public
toutefois il me semblerait avant
d'entreprendre votre réforme extrêmement
intéressant qu'on ait une évaluation de
du de ce qu'on donne en fait de ce qu'a
donné cette expérience c'est sous préfet
à la relance on s'en doute rencontré des
difficultés ils ont sans doute fait des
apports et ils ont eu pour ceux que j'ai
rencontrés une première difficulté c'est
qu'il plongeait avec la nécessité d'une
urgence d'activation du plan de relance
dans un univers qui nécessitait un
background culturel qui n'est pas
forcément ça veut pas dire qu'ils
peuvent pas faire mais moi j'aimerais
bien qu'on ait une évaluation de tout ça
et enfin ne pensez vous pas qu'il serait
souhaitable dans la réforme que vous
entreprenez d'associer très étroitement
le parlement mais aussi les
collectivités je vous remercie madame la
ministre
merci à midi at elle encore deux
interventions monsieur thani mohamed
soilihi est en visioconférence est ce
que il nous entend le voilà oui merci ce
président j'espère que vous avez
parfaitement le bonjour chers collègues
rejoindra ministre merci madame la
ministre
votre présentation du pôle et
clarification que vous avez apporté
je pense que nous pouvons tous
reconnaître que l'objet et les
motivations de cette réforme ne sont pas
nouveaux et qu'ils ont occupée
sans nécessairement aboutir à de
précédents gouvernements ma question
portent plus spécifiquement sur la
procédure
en effet les craintes exprimées sur le
principe de la création d'un corps
unique d'administrateur de l'état ne
doivent pas faire oublier l'importance
que revêtiront la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme les processus d'affectation et
de formation à l'exercice de différentes
fonctions au cours de la carrière
plusieurs pistes ont été évoquées telles
que la création de ce statut d'emploi
peut-être la consultation à venir
permettra t elle de préciser ce point
mais pouvez vous administre d'ores et
déjà revenir sur les modalités
procédurales de la tua garantir que
cette réforme qui vise à lutter contre
le déterminisme dans la carrière et à
favoriser la mobilité opérationnel et
l'interministérialité d'objets objectif
vous qui pourrez le nous a semblé
ménagera non seulement la neutralité
politique
cela a été abordé mais également les
spécificités et les compétences propres
des différentes fonctions de
l'encadrement supérieur de l'état
je vous remercie merci et enfin monsieur
jean yves le conte
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je réfère à un préalable et
vous poser deux questions préalables
c'est que nous sommes dans un pays où
nous pouvons presque considérer que
l'état a d'une certaine manière précédé
la nation et et que par conséquent c'est
pas juste anecdotique que de réformer la
haute fonction publique parce que c'est
quelque part notre colonne vertébrale
d'ailleurs vous l'avez rappelé et
l'esprit du conseil national de
résistance la création de l'est là ça a
été un moment fort
nous pouvons je pense tous ici nous
accordé pour faire pour dire que
probablement compte tenu des évolutions
il y a besoin de réformes pour adapter
autant pour peut-être aussi contrer
certaines dérives d'interaction
public-privé au plus haut niveau de la
fonction publique en matière de
déontologie et pour améliorer
l'efficacité de l'action publique mais
puisqu'il s'agit de notre colonne
vertébrale j'allais dire nationale je
suis un peu étonné que ça passe par
ordonnance comme cela parce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose de fondamental je
dirais même que par rapport aux
principes de la république
c'est parler des principes de la
république qui finalement sont justes
engendrés par la nation alors que là on
parle vraiment de ce qu'a fondé le pays
c est un peu décalé donc je crois
vraiment que c'est un sujet essentiel de
ma première question vous avez un peu
moqué les gens qui évoquait le ce pôle
systèmes et c'était un peu quand même
l'esprit du président de la république
lorsque nommé il a demandé à d'avoir des
cabines est finalement relativement
faible pour avoir des directions des
directeurs de l'administration qui soit
capable finalement d'assumer directement
les politiques sans avoir des cabinets
qui contrôle derrière président de la
république a même évoqué en conférence
des ambassadeurs l'état profond une
notion finalement un peu un peu
complotistes et est donc j'aurai une
question par rapport à ça pensez vous
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un problème de
contrôle de la haute fonction publique
par le politique
et si oui est-ce que c'est un problème
politique des politiques ou est-ce que
cette robe qui lie à la fonction
publique est ce que c'est la compétence
des politiques qui est en cause leur
comportement ou est ce que c'est le
comportement de la haute fonction
publique
voilà et je crois que c'est de cette
question doit aussi découler une part de
la manière dont on doit orienter la
réforme et la deuxième question elle est
très simple c'est dans le cadre de cette
réforme
quelles nouvelles garanties pouvons nous
avoir pour faire en sorte que la justice
administrative qui a une place de plus
importante dans la vie du pays et pour
garantir nos libertés progresse en
matière d'impartialité et d'indépendance
à l'occasion de cette réforme
merci chers collègues eh bien nous en
avons terminé klaas-jan question madame
la ministre vous avez la parole alors
merci à vous tous pour vos questions qui
montre et je crois vous a été plusieurs
à le dire à quel point cette réforme
effectivement n'est absolument pas
anecdotique quand vous l'avez dit la
nation et l'état en france entretiennent
une relation qui est presque
consubstantiel c'est pourquoi j'ai
président j'ai tenu la présenter en
détails sachant parfois les ordonnances
ne sont connus des membres du parlement
qu'une fois qu'elles sont déposés sur le
bureau
les assemblées ou du sénat et qu'il le
semble utile en tout cas de le faire en
grande transparence à la fois vis-à-vis
des premiers concernés que sont les
hauts fonctionnaires c'est pour ça que
le président s'est adressé à eux le 8
avril pour ça que nous lançons dans la
phase de mise en oeuvre maintenant une
consultation et qui me semble
extrêmement précieux dagard 17 ouverture
cette transparence
c'est effectivement une ordonnance et je
pense qu'il faut lactée en tant que tel
c'est une annonce qui découle d'une loi
longuement débattu qui a fait l'objet de
beaucoup de travail parlementaire en
2019 et nous travaillons ici dans le
cadre pleinement j'allais dire
république et à constitutionnel qui nous
permet de créer de la matière
législative dans un processus qui est
celui des ordonnances évidemment la
ratification découlera du dépôt dans les
délais sur le bureau des assemblées et
évidemment vous imaginez bien que je ne
peux pas moins ici m'engager sur l'ordre
du jour au nom du gouvernement ou mais
je tiens à vous dire que je suis à votre
entière disposition pour d'ailleurs
revenir devant votre commission dans
quelques mois pour suivre la mise en
oeuvre et le suivi de ce que cette
ordonnance pose comme principe mais qui
sera ensuite suivie d'un travail
réglementaire très approfondie donc
voilà en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire ce sujet j'aimerais peut-être
revenir sur un stand de thématiques qui
ont été évoquées par les uns et les
autres pour être dans le plus grand
niveau de détails est
je vous remercie d'ailleurs pour la
qualité des échanges qui montre qu'on
peut avoir sur ce sujet je crois un
travail en tout cas en grande maturité
collective et ce qu'ils sortent un peu
des invectives et de la simplification
de certains débats je tiens d'abord à me
pencher sur le fait du corps préfectoral
qui a été évoqué par vous même la
rapporteure par monsieur le questeur
philippe bas et à ce nombre d'entre vous
mènera notamment madame gatel mais
beaucoup d'autres d'abord il ya moins de
choses assez faux c'est finalement assez
grave qui sont dites depuis quelques
jours sur le corps préfectoral
nous ne voulons pas politiser les
préfets et nous ne voulons pas supprimer
une institution qui remonte à napoléon
et je crois qu'il faut le dire je le
réaffirme vraiment sans ambiguïté nous
sommes très attachés entend gouvernement
à cette institution et au delà aux
fonctionnaires qui exercent un métier
très particulier qui n'existe dans aucun
autre pays de sous préfets et préfets
parce qu'ils représentent l'armature
essentielles de l'état dans les
territoires et je vais le dire aussi
prosaïquement que vous le savez l'une et
l'autre dit il n'ya là aucune punition
et aucune remise en question des hommes
et des femmes qui exercent ce métier
mais construire une carrière acquérir un
métier développer une éthique
professionnelle
si l'on croit à une gestion la dir
moderne des ressources humaines peut se
faire et même je dirais doit se faire à
l'extérieur accord pour permettre
davantage d'ouverture et de mobilité
toute notre action depuis 2007 autour du
président la république a été de
réaffirmer la place centrale des préfets
de la république et ce gouvernement sous
l'autorité du premier ministre a
effectivement placé le couple maires
préfets au coeur de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
nos préfets sont conformément à la
constitution les premiers représentants
de l'état dans les territoires qui
doivent donc agir au plus proche de
leurs concitoyens assurer que nos
politiques publiques se déploie jusqu'au
dernier kilomètre au bénéfice des
usagers avec l'esprit désormais actée et
précises et de la différenciation parce
que les politiques publiques ne se met
pas en oeuvre de la même manière selon
les territoires et preuve en est s'il le
fallait notre attachement à leur rôle
c'est effectivement madame la présidente
vous avez cité la création c'est 30
poste de sous préfet à la relance sur
tout le territoire qui sont un envoi de
renforts aux côtés des préfets pour
porter cette politique prioritaire du
gouvernement qui est la relance à la
fois économiques des compétences
environnementales
c'est aussi autre signal que nous
envoyons très fort l'augmentation des
postes à la sortie de l'ena dès 2021
dans les services déconcentrés
l'objectif étant par ailleurs je voulais
dit que l'ensemble des administrateurs
de l'état commence désormais leur
carrière dans des fonctions
opérationnelles et pour une grande
partie d'entre eux cela se produira dans
des opérateurs publics mais aussi dans
des services déconcentrés et donc dans
une proximité beaucoup plus grande avec
nos concitoyens et en lien avec
évidemment les préfets cet engagement et
leur rôle je mesure pleinement vous
savez dans les déplacements que je fais
chaque semaine dans le cas des suivi de
la mise en oeuvre de politiques
prioritaires et de nos résultats
l'enjeu de cette réforme c'est vraiment
passer à une logique de compétences et
le métier et donc la réforme de
l'encadrement super l'habitat n'a pas
pour objectif de supprimer le métier de
préfet je rappelle d'ailleurs que le
corps des préfets a été créée en 1950
mais surtout renforcé en 1964 et que
donc entre le moment où les préfets ont
commencé à être nommés par le pouvoir
exécutif et le moment où il a fallu en
créer un corps s'est passé plus d'un
siècle et demi ce qui montre que le
métier a été longtemps détaché d'une
vision de corps administratif et le but
n'est pas de favoriser les nominations
politiques sur les emplois les préfets
ont toujours été nommés par le pouvoir
exécutif est depuis le début de la vème
république en conseil des ministres donc
contrairement à ce que l'on peut
entendre là n'est pas l'enjeu la réforme
du corps des sous préfets des préfets
s'inscrit dans le développement d'une
logique d'organisation des parcours de
carrière sont les métiers les
compétences qui ne se dicte pas
forcément par l'appartenance à un corps
les fonctionnaires qui accéderont à ces
emplois appartiendront encore des amis
sera de l'état mais également comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui à d'autres
corps et cadres d'emplois comparables le
recrutement devrait dont fondations et
simples compétences en tenant compte de
l'expérience professionnelle et donc
nous créons un statut d'emploi sujet qui
a été évoquée qui sera propre fonction
préfectorale qui sera élaboré pour
renforcer la vocation d'ouverture du
corps des préfets les sous-préfets
revers l'extérieur à croître donc leur
capacité à conduire des projets et la
connaissance de l'état déconcentré par
les 4
les centrales le but étant d'organiser
une mobilité plus grande entre les
fonctions normative des amis centrale et
les fonctions de mise en oeuvre réelle
de terrain l'enjeu est donc on le voit
de valoriser dans la carrière de
l'encens de nos fonctionnaires c'est
passage deux ans mise en oeuvre de
terrain parce qu'aujourd'hui on s'est
passé un bout de sa carrière dans un
service déconcentré et plutôt vu comme
un frein ralentissement de carrière
qu'une valorisation
le but du statut d'emploi c'est donc de
tenir compte des nécessités
opérationnelles des métiers de mieux
reconnaître les spécificités des
fonctions exercées par les actuels
membres du corps les contraintes qui les
accompagnent mais ce qu'on a mis des
suggestions et donc d'affecter les
personnes en fonction leurs compétences
et leur expérience
vous l'avez dit madame la présidente la
clé c'est que l'état connaissent bien
ces besoins
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'à partir du
baromètre des restaveks en public nous
définissions des feuilles de route pour
chaque département qui re priorise
l'action que l'état doit mener dont elle
était le territoire et donc avec des
moyens qui suivent moyens budgétaires
moyens en ressources humaines et qu'un
état qui connaît bien ses besoins c'est
un état qui peut du coup mettre les
bonnes personnes avec si je suis
transparente
la progression aujourd'hui dans les
postes préfectoraux se fait en fonction
du nombre d'habitants et pas en fonction
des besoins du territoire et donc cette
allocation entre les compétences et les
besoins les aspirations aussi de tel ou
tel un moment donné sa carrière
aujourd'hui ce fait très difficilement
et de manière parfois je dire plus par
hasard que de manière organisée
évidemment ce statut d'emploi on le voit
garantir à l'impartialité ca sud en
point il pose et d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça qu'on crée un corps des ennemis
sûreté de l'état
nous ne sommes pas en train ici de
contractualiser avec un statut de droit
privé
l'ensemble de la haute fonction publique
parce que nous croyons précisément aux
valeurs de neutralité d'impartialité
d'égalité de traitement de laïcité que
le statut de la fonction publique permet
j'entendais sur certains de vos amis de
la famille politique des uns et les
autres que certains proposerait que nous
passions directement ou cdi droit privé
pour tout le monde si nous faisons ça
alors oui les questions d'impartialité
de neutralité se poserait demain
réguler bien sûr que nous allons donc
tenir dans ce cadre là beaucoup plus
compte en fait qu'aujourd'hui des
compétences et des expériences et sortir
d'une logique de progression à
l'ancienneté et pour passer dans une
vraie valorisation des compétences et
donc des métiers le but je le dis c'est
de conforter les fonctions préfectorales
d'accroître l'attractivité pour les
cadres supérieurs de l'état de ses
fonctions et donc de préserver de
renforcer cette institution qui est clé
pour les élus et pour les 20 ans de
notre pays pourquoi c'était je pense un
premier sujet qui est si tu es d'être
clarifié les statuts d'emploi pour y
revenir sont effectivement donc déployé
pour les fonctions préfectorales
monsieur le sénateur le compte mais
également évidemment pour les
inspections puisque je vais revenir la
question du quai deux messieurs questa
les travaux ont déjà commencé avec les
différents ministères donc sur la miss à
l'intérieur également avec les
différents services d'inspection pour
que nous définissions précisément
quelles sont les règles applicables à
ces emplois quelles sont les compétences
à mobiliser pour pouvoir accéder à ces
postes qu'elles sont aussi la
valorisation qu'on peut avoir de ces
postes dans une carrière et que donc on
crée le cadre qui permet sur des enjeux
de reconnaissance financière des
fonctions exercées mais aussi la durée
des postes et conditions de
renouvellement les conditions de fargues
fonction un cadre qui donne de la
visibilité de la prévisibilité sur les
inspections générales qui fait suite du
coup à 7 à cette explication
d'abord nous ne voulons pas fusionner
les inspections générales
interministériel
c'était une idée qui a longtemps circulé
ce n'est pas notre objectif puisque si
nous croyons métier nous croyons qu'en
même temps de spécialisation en tout cas
on croit pas aux généralistes qui
pourraient forcément tout faire dans
tous les domaines nous ne voulons pas
non plus remettre en cause l'importance
et la qualité de ses travaux réalisés
notamment pour aider à la prise de
décision publique
avec un regard qui propose recul et
impartialité
ce qui va se passer c'est qu'à partir de
2023 il y aura plus d'accès direct ou
encore et donc plus accès direct au
corps d'inspection ministériel
en revanche ses services pour recruter
beaucoup plus largement
en fait des personnes qui auront au
moins 2 ans d'expérience avant avant
de se présenter et des expériences
opérationnelles en contrepartie la fin
des recrutements en direct dans les
corps nous avons introduit dans
l'article 7 de l'ordonance présenté au
conseil d'état décrit dans la loi en
fait des choses qui n'ont jamais été
écrite au niveau de la loi vous
considérez que le corps suffisait à
garantir l'impartialité et la neutralité
des garanties légales donc
d'indépendance d'impartialité
c'est une reconnaissance inédite au
niveau législatif c'est un gage que ces
missions d'audit d'évaluation
d'inspection seront donc bien exercer
dans des conditions qui permettront aux
auteurs de le faire avec l'impartialité
nécessaire
en complément des garanties légales nous
avons aussi précisé les spécificités des
métiers pour que là aussi le statut
d'emploi qui sera créé puis 7
et on fait en concertation avec les
chefs de corps c'est extrêmement
important et les représentants syndicaux
que ce statut d'emploi précise les
modalités d'accès dans les emplois leur
durée leurs modalités d'avancement et la
manière dont on sort de ces inspections
pour que sa progression de carrière
dépendent pas seulement du ministre pour
qui on a écrit des rapports
d'où le rôle de la délégation
interministérielle dans ce cadre là nous
avons dans le projet d'ordonnancé
précisé par donc au niveau législatif le
fait que les chefs de services
d'inspection seront nommés sur une dent
dure et d'emploi renouvelables ne
pourront être démis de leurs fonctions
que dans des cas très particuliers
extrêmement encadrée et donc protéger
d'une quelconque intrusion politique
c'est donc une responsabilisation au
fond qui permet que permet ce statut
d'emploi pour que les recrutements soit
la main des chefs de service dans une
logique de métiers de compétence est
plus dans une logique de statuts
là aussi nous supprimons pas les métiers
mais nous leur mettons en phase avec la
respiration nécessaire aussi de ceux qui
ont des compétences dans ces inspections
pour qu'ils puissent être amenés en
fonction des expériences la compétence à
prendre des responsabilités dans des
postes d'administration active comme on
peut lire sujets suivants sur laquelle
vous avez interrogé c'est donc pour la
cohérence de l'animation un terminal du
parcours de ressources humaines et donc
le rôle notamment la délégation
interministérielle sa part demandé si
elle aurait assez de moyens
oui nous allons y mettre des moyens
c'est entre 30 et 50 personnes qui vont
être là pour deux
la cohérence et qui est pas de
déperdition de ressources injustifiable
pour nos concitoyens
je pense notamment à tous ces hauts
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui qui parce
qu'ils sont dans un ministère ou un
accord ne se voit pas offrir de
perspectives après à son expérience
parce que leurs perspectives ou leur
voie de progression sont au fond assez
réduite au sein du seul ministère où ils
ont travaillé une grande partie de leur
vie la délégation interministérielle
dont comptera 30 à 50 personnes je le
disais c'est beaucoup plus que la somme
de l'ensemble des agents qui aujourd'hui
dans les différents ministères ont en
charge l'encadrement supérieur
c'est un vrai investissement entre mise
en cohérence une des missions de la diez
donc sera d'orienter les cadres
supérieurs dans leur parcours de
carrière de se rendre disponible pour
échanger avec eux sur leurs aspirations
c'est un mot qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
dans le cadre de la stratégie de
l'encadrement supérieur les aspirations
personnelles ne sont pas un élément pris
en compte en tant que tel qui puisse
aussi penser avec les agents publics les
besoins de formation de reconversion
d'évolution vers la fonction
territoriale vers un autre ministère
vers la fonction publique hospitalière
voir vers le privé c'est lé soin notre
réforme avis quand même a construit des
carrières complètes et à redonner des
vraies perspectives de moyen de long
terme à chacun ce sera au fond une drh
talent qui proposera aussi une offre de
services d'accompagnement cadres
supérieurs et donc faciliter cette
mobilité
elle aura aussi en charge la mise en
application avec les ministères ce qu'on
appelle les lignes directrices de
gestion interministériel c'est à une
vraie stratégie rh assumer transparente
connu qui donnera la visibilité à chacun
sur le spoil system monsieur le sénateur
donc je récuse ce terme parce que c'est
c'est la vision d'un monde administratif
vous avez parlé de modèle à la française
qui n'est pas le nôtre
nous ne demandons pas dans notre pays à
quiconque de savoir quelle est sa
couleur politique
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a un statut
c'est vous a comparé d'impartialité de
neutralité
ce qui est certain c'est que nous
cherchons et je crois que c'est plutôt
sain pour la république que ceux qui
sont chargés de mettre en oeuvre une
politique soit loyaux à ce qui
représente le gouvernement
démocratiquement élu qui propose cette
politique
vous savez depuis 2007 on a renouvelé
87% de directeur de mission centrale qui
le
mouvement qui a été initiée et que je
crois qu'à chaque fois ça a été fait
pour que ce qu'ils soient charles mettre
en oeuvre les politiques soient d'accord
avec la politique au lendemain de mettre
en oeuvre ce qui n'est pas une question
d'appartenance politique il ya des
hommes qui viennent de toutes couleurs
politiques on leur demande parce qu'il
vote dans l'isoloir
donc je pense qu'il faut avoir avec cet
enjeu de la politisation une grande
prudence a pas de reprise en main du
politique sur la haute administration en
revanche iliad assumer que les rôles
sont différents que le politique
représente la démocratie qui élit un
gouvernement un exécutif et que la haute
fonction publique à sa charge la mise en
oeuvre avec loyauté efficacité et ce qui
créera du coup la confiance dans un
président de le disait la confiance s
regagnera par l'efficacité notre
capacité à traduire les mots et les lois
en résultats visibles
madame la rapporteuse vont interroger du
coup sûr le rapport thiriez je prends
maintenant un peu plus vos questions les
plus spécifiques des uns et des autres
d'abord c'est un travail je crois qui a
été extrêmement important c'est une
contribution un débat qui existe on voit
depuis des décennies qui a été une
contribution essentielle à la réflexion
n'a pas été le seul élément évidemment
dans parce qu'il est écrit un moment
avant la crise sanitaire et donc à ce
nombre de choses et y était révélé
peut-être avec encore plus d'acuité
nous gardons la proposition du tronc
commun aux écoles de service public des
trois versants donc territoriale
hospitalier et à nous gardons l'idée que
les corps techniques seront inclus dans
la démarche même si ce sera dans un
deuxième temps il faut faire les choses
quand même de manière séquencée pour
être crédible nous gardons l'idée qu'il
n'ya plus sorti dans les grands corps et
qui a un passage par le terrain en début
de carrière
nous gardons l'ange de la
diversification des recrutements et la
dynamisation des carrières comme des
coups de choses même si notre réforme
voilà va plus loin sur le pantouflage
monsieur le sénateur maintenant vous
dire que la loi de 2009 a quand même
largement renforcé les obligations et
donc
mais avant qu'une loi doivent être
changées il faut déjà que la première
s'applique donc
salut de 2010 elle s'applique
aujourd'hui elle a permis d'élargir les
compétences de l'achat tvp elle a aussi
permis un contrôle au retour et plus
seulement au départ dont le secteur
privé
c'est 300 contrôles qui ont été menées
en 2020 mais donc temps vous dire que
les choses sont aujourd'hui actives mais
je tiens à dire deux choses d'abord je
ne souhaite pas je ne crois pas que ce
souhaitable que la fonction publique
devienne une île elle a besoin de se
connecter c'est pour ça qu'on valorise
les stages en et pme qu'on valorise les
stages dans est d'ailleurs le troisième
concours qui est aussi une manière de
faire entrer des profils différents
deuxième chose nous incitons je lui ai
dit et nous cherchons à redonner des
perspectives de moyen et de long terme à
l'ensemble des faux des hauts
fonctionnaires
nous pouvons pas imaginer uniquement une
autre fonction publique où les gens
viendraient asservir quelques missions
et donc oui on doit donner des
perspectives de carrière à tous le but
n'est pas d'organiser un départ massif
vers le privé
je tiens vraiment à récuser cette idée
mais que pour ceux qui voudraient se
reconvertir et je tiens à dire aussi
quelque chose qui est assez méconnue
nous avons encadré maintenant par des
périodes de deux fois cinq ans le temps
maximum que quelqu'un peut passer en
dehors de la fonction publique
période au terme de laquelle on ne peut
plus revenir en tant que fonctionnaire
et notamment nous avons fait maintenant
appliquer strictement fameux
remboursement financiers de ceux qui
quitteraient la fonction publique avant
la durée qui correspond à l'information
sur les juridictions administratives et
financières et notamment la partialité
et la manière de recruter
d'abord oui nous devons respecter la
constitution et donc il n'était pas
envisageable d'imaginer que l'ensemble
des magistrats financiers ou
administratifs sont les animateurs de
l'état et non pas des personnes
rattachées à l'institution qui roulait
principe d'inamovibilité d'impartialité
sont de rang constitutionnel
mais ces institutions ne sont pas les
quarts des réformes je tiens à dire
aussi très précisément d'abord il ya
plus d'élèves qui iront directement
rejoindre les corps à la sortie de
l'école
puisque chacun devra donc commencé par
être en administration active avant de
juger au contrôle et ça concerne autant
le conseil d'état la cour des comptes
également que les conseillers tribunaux
administratifs et des cours
administratives d'appel et conseillers
des chambres régionales des comptes et
donc les corps des magistrats des
auditions administrative et financière
se verront appliquer les mêmes principes
d'ouverture de mobilité obligatoire
avant de passer des graves d'évaluation
et avec cette culture du recrutement
c'est à dire que beaucoup plus de
personnes pourront travailler dans ces
institutions
avant de se présenter potentiellement
pour une intégration avec le président
du sénat et de l'assemblée
or on a nommé les personnes
indépendantes qui veilleront à la non
cooptation et un nom et poti sme dans
l'intégration dans ces corps et donc
c'est bien leur indépendance et leur
part impartialité qui sera garantie
trois sujets maintenant qu'ils sont un
peu plus éloigné la réforme à demain
mais qui sont plus des enjeux
d'efficacité j'allais dire de l'action
publique sur lequel vous m'avez
interrogé sur le principe du silence
vaut acceptation d'abord vous citez
l'incomplétude des procédures qui sont
soumises à la règle et vous dites font
qu'il ya un principe général qui a
beaucoup de trous si je le résume en
langage trivial ce que vous avez dit moi
mon premier objectif c'est que
l'administration répondent et je pense
que c'est un objectif d'abord qu'il faut
fixer en tant que tel et nous avons
aujourd'hui dans les indicateurs de
performance d'administration ce que
j'appelle le taux de décroché le taux de
réponse quant aux délais de réponse
parce que je pense que un pays où on
enverrait des lettres dans l'espoir que
personne ne vous répondre on
commencerait à tourner un peu à
l'absurde
néanmoins néanmoins il est absolument
clair et vous avez cité des exemples je
vais revenir sur l'archéologie
préventive une ax une administration qui
gère la confiance c'est une
administration qui facilite accompagne
et qui différencie c'est parfois moi je
dis aux agents de des services
déconcentrés des choses simples
peut-être par exemple ne plus dire non
un projet sans être allé voir sur les
lieux l'ampleur du projet ou les
aménagements qui pourraient être
proposés au projet pour qu'il se fasse
que nous soyons beaucoup plus dans
l'appui et beaucoup moins dans le
contrôle que nous passions d'une culture
la norme et on a encore parlé hier même
la rapporteure dans le cadre des loisirs
utiles à une culture de la mise en
oeuvre efficace et opérationnel c'est
bien tout le rôle du droit la dérogation
je vais revenir et ses droits la
différenciation et donc oui le silence
vaut acceptation quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'on évalue on regarde mais moi je
peux vous dire que je travaille d'abord
pour les gens vous répondre sur
l'archéologie préventive
c'est plus largement plutôt qu'un
contrôle tatillon ex post c'est comment
nous avons une logique d'appeler au
territoire d'appui aux élus d'appui aux
entreprises il ya deux choses que je
sois qu'elle voulait revenir sur
l'archéologie préventive et dans quatre
des aidants la loi zappe
on a quand même essayé de simplifier
beaucoup de choses et ensuite c'est le
principe de france expérimentation je
vais vous parler c'est un service qui
permet aux élus à aux entreprises de le
d'avoir accès à de la dérogation
législatives ou réglementaires
à partir du moment où on considère qu'un
projet suffisamment innovant et
d'ampleur pour que cette dérogation soit
activée
soit c'est au niveau de l'innovation et
donc du droit plutôt des entreprises
soit c'est par le préfet les français
expérimentation je vous invite à le
connaître parce que c'est un avis un
outil très efficace pour nos pme tpe
le pays et entreprises et territoires il
faut pas que le droit d'aujourd'hui
empêche la croissance de demain
parce que les lois d'hier ont été
pensées sur des objets d'activité qui
n'existait pas quand les choses ont été
écrites sur la dérogation je vais vous
répondre par écrit à la présidente mais
je tiens à redire ici partager les
éléments que j'avais partagé avec vous
d'abord c'est donc une expérimentation
qui a été mené entre 2019 et 2020 qui
est donc été généralisé en août 2020 le
bilan c 130 arrêté pris majoritairement
au bénéfice des collectivités pour une
centaine de ces arrêtés et le but est
d'accroître les recours aux bénéfices du
secteur privé d'où ce que nous allons
renforcer dans la loi 4d sur france
expérimentations et pour france
exportations ces 250 dossiers déposés la
moitié globalement à coquelles il a été
apporté une solution positive et c'est
donc les préfets mais on va vous
et le bilan qui avait fait d'ailleurs
les services miss à l'intérieur sur les
difficultés et les aspects positifs
cette dérogation
merci mme la ministre alors madame
difool cour souhaitait la parole oui
c'est possible mais c'est président
juste pour deux ou trois précisions bon
on entend tous beaucoup de critiques de
tous corps d'état envers cette réforme
et notamment venant de l'ena et des
anciens élèves de l'ena donc fallait-il
vraiment supprimer les notes qu est-ce
qui a présidé à cette décision assez
radical finalement les conséquences et
que un concours est ouvert cette année
donc des élèves vont passer ce concours
mais l'école n'existera plus donc que
va-t-il se passer de façon très concrète
et puis justement le sas peut-être à la
bronca ce le premier ministre a annoncé
le lancement d'une concertation dans les
prochaines semaines donc comment
abordez-vous cette concertation comment
va-t-elle se passer avec qui et pour
quelle quelle finalité
merci merci et rapporteur messieurs
philippe bas vous voyez également une
question un peu précises et techniques
peut-être il y avez vous déjà en partie
répondu comment se feront les
recrutements en qualité d'auditeur à la
cour des comptes et au conseil d'état
question précise d'autres questions
merci l'ami dit c'est sûr d'abord l'ena
je crois que ça fait des années voire
des décennies que je crois que sur tous
les bancs avant même que je sois dans
ses fonctions on va toujours entendu un
concert de critiques sur l'ena je ne
remonte pas à 1995 quand un candidat à
la présidentielle avec est devenu
président suit avait lui-même proposé à
dire que cette école soit supprimée
parce qu'il avait listé un nombre de
difficultés tout en reconnaissant le
besoin de formes évidemment nos hauts
fonctionnaires maintenant que vous avez
bien compris que c'était plus une
suppression refondation une suppression
pure et simple
au fond tout le monde est dans un
concert de louanges et donc je pense
qu'il ya un peu d'étonnement de ma part
c'est qu' il fallait avec eux des
critiques et maintenant et que des
louanges
d'abord moi je sais pas du tout où on a
caricaturé bon je pense que l'ena a
apporté beaucoup à notre pays que les
hommes et les femmes qu'elle a formés
ont apporté beaucoup à notre pays mais
je pense que beaucoup des hommes et des
femmes qu'elle a formés sont aujourd'hui
et ils l'ont été dans le temps assez
clair sur le fait que la formation
pourrait pu évoluer car ce sont aussi de
pratiquer notamment par le poids du
classement qui était devenu un facteur
extrêmement déterminant pour l'ensemble
des carrières est extrême opposants et
que donc il y avait des choses à revoir
nous allons au bout effectivement d'une
réponse est donc si vous regarder en
détail nous changeons la fois la
gouvernance la tutelle l'émission le
périmètre
l'enjeu du tronc commun et donc se poser
un moment donné la question est ce qu'on
dit qu'on garde en font un nom et une
coquille pour tout changer ou est-ce
qu'on a su ou qu'on est en train de
changer profondément bien sûr sans
renier les apports et des choses très
positives ont regardé mais qu'on va
beaucoup plus loin puisque peut-être un
nom mais peut-être aussi une marque qui
qui qui rayonne à l'international veut
c'est quand même prestigieux lehner a un
prestige au niveau international donc
comment garder ou reconquérir ce
prestige avec une autre coquille
alors moi je crois d'ailleurs j'ai plus
que la marque et nauru la marque ian sp
moi je crois la marque france je pense
que ce qu'on a créé c'est notre activité
pour des cadres publics étrangers pour
qui vient de se former aliens sp demain
et notre capacité à former donc
une forme d'élite européennes
internationales mais pas tellement parce
qu'on voulait leur montrer ce qu'est
notre administration est plutôt à ce
qu'est la france comment elle aborde les
enjeux d'universalisme républicain
comment elle aborde les enjeux de
développement comment elle aborde les
enjeux sociaux c'est plutôt ça qu'on
doit construire
je suis très attaché vous savez allier
respect dans son rayonnement européen
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que dès février
2022 dans le cas de la présidence
française de l'union européenne je
réunirai mes homologues dans les locaux
donc de lier un aspect à strasbourg et
donc il ya pas de reniement de son de
son rôle au contraire et au delà du non
moi je pense que passer dans une école
d'administration à l'insu du service
public illustre aussi le changement de
culture que nous voulons proposer léon
duguit qui était commun doyen illustre
avait rappelé que la finalité de
l'action publique était le service
public
je pense qu'il ya aussi voyez dans la
démarche que nous ayons construire un
attachement très fort assez à ses
principes
donc ne soyons pas agréé dans la
caricature en 45 quand vous réalisez les
travaux préparatoires à la ordonnance
l'enjeu était de refondre la machine
administrative française aujourd'hui
nous mettons donc sur pied cette ce
nouvel institut est donc la formation
sera surtout esquissera nouveau beaucoup
plus en lien avec le monde académique je
tiens à signaler que moi je crois
beaucoup modèle français
l'administration mais il ya quand même
une particularité en france qui je pense
est plutôt une faiblesse c'est que nous
sommes un des rares pays au monde
nous avons autant éloigné les décideurs
publics de ceux qui produisent la
connaissance les chercheurs le monde
académique dans l'ensemble des pays du
monde on considère que les décideurs
publics gagne à être beaucoup plus en
lien avec ce qui au fond anime la
recherche et que les chercheurs
eux-mêmes gagne aussi à comprendre les
complexités de la décision publique
collective dans toutes ses dents toutes
ses faces elle est donc lié en espèces
sera beaucoup plus en lien avec le monde
académique à la fois français et
européens
son souvenir sur les concours en cours
sur les élèves qui sont actuellement en
cours de préparation et c'est d'abord il
ya un principe c'est pas le principe de
confiance légitime et donc on ne change
jamais ni un concours d'idées épreuve
pour des gens qui sont en cours de
préparation
les élèves qui préparent aujourd'hui
l'ena passeront les épreuves pour
lesquels ils se préparent ils
intègreront donc effectivement lee à
nestlé au 1er janvier 2022
et ils en sortiront comme admis ses
intérêts de l'état dans la nouvelle
procédure
il ya une réflexion évidente sur les
épreuves notamment quelles sont les
compétences convenu de ce comporte deux
loups version du socle de formation qui
est qui est à l'oeuvre mais ça
s'appliquera au cvec forcément le délai
nécessaire pour que personne ne soit
privée de ses capacités à réussir un
concours 6 et prépare déjà
enfin sur la consultation c'est un point
important vous voyez bien qu'il ya un
séquençage de la réforme il ya ce que le
président a proposé présenté aux cadres
de l'état qui étaient les objectifs
interministériel et donc de l'ordonance
qui vient remplacer celle de 45 que vous
présentant la semaine prochaine et
ensuite il ya un immense chantier
réglementaire qui va se décliner selon
les fameux statut d'emploi sont les
ministères sont les employeurs publics
et qui demande la ne pas avoir d' angles
morts d'être dans un niveau de finesse
qui correspond à la diversité des
profils et donc la consultation que je
lance demain c'est une consultation qui
permet à l'ensemble des dix mille et
plus cadres de l'état de faire part avec
une vingtaine de questions à la fois
très simple mais qui vont être mon avis
très précieuses qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui d'un regard sur leur
fonction et sur leurs perspectives de
carrière je lisais les aspirations
individuelles des hauts fonctionnaires
sont une matière qui n'est à fond banier
entendu inexploitées et donc la base
pour construire des parcours de carrière
pour mettre en place la fameuse
délégation interministérielle pour
réfléchir à des angles morts éventuels
qui ne seraient pas apparues parce qu'il
ya une grande diversité de métiers
c'est le but de cette consultation et se
déroule jusqu'au 18 juin
les contes les conclusions seront
rendues publiques et une
retour sera présenté au premier ministre
à moi-même d'ici fin juillet début
juillet pardon sûr maintenant la
question très spécifique du recrutement
des auditeurs d'abord vous dire que
c'est en cours de discussion au conseil
d'état sur le questeur et que donc je
vous présente ce que nous avons nous
même proposé en attente évidemment du
retour précis du conseil d'état la
manière dont les choses vont se passer
c'est que donc nous supprimons l'accès
direct de la sortie de scolarité
directement donc dans les fonctions du
corps qui étaient donc les auditeurs à
la fois au conseil la cour nous
instaurons principe que tout le monde ne
commencera sur le terrain et donc au
bout de deux ans au moins deux ans mais
ça peut être 3 4 6 sera au moins 2 ans
d'expérience professionnelle les élèves
de liens sp mais aussi de toutes les
corps comparable qu'un administrateur
territorial un cadre hospitalier
l'ensemble de ceux qui ont accord
comparable pourront se présenter pour
être recrutés dans un emploi d'auditeurs
et donc 7
c'est une commission de sélection qui
regardera les profits qui se
présenteront le conseil d'état ouvrira
un stand de postes en fonction de ses
besoins et donc des emplois d'auditeurs
seront ouverts aux termes de cet emploi
d'auditeurs ceux qui le souhaiteront
pourront se présenter devant la
commission d'intégration pour rejoindre
ce qui est aujourd'hui le 2ème grade du
corps qui deviendra du coup le grade
d'entrée cette commission intégration
sera une commission paritaire
trois membres du conseil d'état ou de la
cour trois membres extérieurs un désigné
par le président du sénat un désigné par
l'assemblée nationale
un désigné par le président la
république et la règle c'est que cette
commission d'intégration aura regardé
les qualités et les mérites de la
personne dans sa fonction de terrain
opérationnel dans les travaux qu'elle
aura pu faire en tant que dans l'emploi
d'auditeurs corps a été le sien et pour
que la personne soit intégré il faut au
moins quatre votes n'y a pas de voix
prépondérante
ce qui assure qu' il faut qu'il ait une
forme de consensus
la personne donc fasse consensus auprès
non seulement des palanques des
personnes internes à de l'institution
mais aussi à au moins une personne
externe l'institution
et donc ça c'est pour les emplois
d'auditeurs nous avons privé le conseil
d'état qui est aussi d'autres voies
d'entrée à d'autres moments à des gens
qui ont 6 ans d'expérience vite en
expérience 10 ans d'expérience en
ouvrant beaucoup plus le type de profil
et donc de personnes avec leurs
expériences et compétences qui pourront
entrer au conseil d'état d'abord pour
exercer des postes les emplois avant à
nouveau de se présenter la commission
d'intégration et le but l'esprit de la
réforme
il ya beaucoup travaillé à la fois et
bruno lasserre et pierre moscovici c'est
que on soit intégrée sur la base de la
qualité son travail et donc de son envie
aussi de faire partie du corps parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un système qui
a c'est un peu étrange dans la une
vision de ressources humaines
c'est que rentrer dans ces corps pour y
faire carrière des personnes qu'ils sont
au titre du classement ou authier de
nomination finalement au gouvernementale
donc voilà le le principe est donc ce
sont des les auditeurs seront recrutés
par une commission de sélection ne sont
pas membres du corps et pourront le
devenir après avoir fait bon de qualité
et d'une évaluation des madame même
défaut que vous lire on prend la parole
puis ensuite monsieur sur j'habite
peut-être président mais juste j'ai pas
question donc travailler je voulais
rebondir sur la dir est dans la
direction interministérielle vous dites
30 à 40 personnes qui vont finalement
créé une drh talent
il y aura-t-il une traduction budgétaire
prochain ça se verra ça sera
effectivement va y consacrer néracais
quand l'état met des moyens ça se voit
oui donc j'examinerai ça et puis
deuxièmement je voulais rebondir un peu
sur sur l'ena et est en fait j'ai
auditionné dans le cadre d'un avis
budgétaire il ya deux ans je crois le
directeur et déjà il avait amorcé une
refonte de du fonctionnement de l'ena
donc j'allais dire au moment peut-être
où elle commence à prendre de l'ampleur
on lui coupe les ailes ou alors vous
allez vous appuyez sur ce qu'il a déjà
mis en place et notamment ce fameux
concours docteur qui parle qui fait une
ouverture sur les sciences celle dont
vous venez de parler d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que je voulais vous interrompre
à ce moment là parce que je voulais
rebondir donc j'allais dire on est déjà
dans une expérimentation d'une réforme
de la scolarisation à l'ena donc oui ce
serait intéressant de rebondir et de
repartir sur cette réforme qui vient
d'être lancée finalement et qui peut
être être intéressante en tout cas ce
serait de masquer le directeur est mis
en place des choses innovantes et que ce
ne soit pas conservé merci beaucoup
madame la rapporteure vous me permettrez
du str pardon si vous en voyez vie après
monsieur sûr vous avez raison j'ai d'un
dialogue sans empressement
l'empressement à désirer pendant un
défaut locaux qui monsieur sua revanche
est d'abord merci à porter vous permet
tout d'abord de rendre hommage au
travail que patrick girard a mené depuis
sa nomination pour initiation de
changement qui rendent la réforme
d'aujourd'hui possible cette réforme
aurait été assez peu crédible si et le
travail sur la voix docteur sur le
rapprochement aussi avec cette
discussion sur la diplomation notamment
en vue d'un potentiel doctorat sur la
refonte de la scolarité pour avoir plus
de compétences sur le stage plutôt dans
une pme
deux reprises dont il ya énormément de
travail qui a été mené qui rend possible
la réforme aujourd'hui et sur laquelle
nous allons évidemment nous appuyer
ensuite
sur donc les votre autre question
préalable les moyens évidemment en
ministre de la fiq a cité de l'action
publique
on y mettra des moyens adaptés qui
découvrons la préfiguration qui sera
fait
et évidemment on le traduira dans les
termes budgétaires si vous me permettez
monsieur le président il ya un point sur
lequel je voulais peut-être venir qui
était la question initiale de monsieur
testeurs on se bat sur les
administrateurs civils parce qu'au fond
si on regarde discussion beaucoup des
sujets qu'on a évoqué des inquiétudes
légitimes et que je évidemment on doit
regarder avec des tailles sont le fruit
l'expression la zone de corps qui sont
très vocaux qui se font entendre mais
j'aimerais aussi qu'on n'oublie pas que
la grande majorité de ceux qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les hauts fonctionnaires
sont des hommes et des femmes qu'on
entend très peu et qui sont les
administrateurs civils que vous avez
cités au départ la promesse initiale de
45 aujourd'hui pour les administrateurs
civils qui travaillent dans l'état n'a
pas été tenue que ce soit en termes de
réelle mobilité interministériel que ce
soit en termes de réelle homogénéité
notamment de rémunération que ce soit
aussi dans l'animation même de ce corps
d'amy certains civils
je pense que on est tous d'accord ici
pour dire que l'état n'est pas à la
hauteur de la promesse qui a été faite
historiquement et qui est fait
implicitement est donc pour eux quand si
la grande majorité
quand même des cadres l'état et la
grande majorité des plus de dix mille
personnes en joue par la réforme que
nous portons et foncièrement positive
parce que en créant le corps d'un
certain d'état nous n'aurons pas de
perdre on nous aurons une harmonisation
de rémunération une formation continue
là où il n'y avait qu'une formation
initiale et parfois pour beaucoup
d'analystes en civil qui était notamment
animé par d'instants de voies internes
qui était très faible
c'est aussi une vraie mobilité
interministériel qu'on rend à nouveau
possible quand vous avez des écarts de
rémunération de 30 à 40% sur les primes
les absences ils ne vont pas d'un
ministère à l'autre
et puis c'est aussi l'accompagnement
individuel que nous allons offrir donc
je vois qu'il ya aussi à valoriser le
fait que c'est positif
c'est très fort merci à monsieur suaire
merci monsieur le président je dois
d'abord présenté des excuses à vous même
monsieur le président madame la ministre
à mes collègues parce que je suis pas
venu en tant d'autres exposés liminaires
tout simplement parce que j'avais une
autre réunion à laquelle je ne pouvais
me dérober avec de brillants
universitaires d'ailleurs juriste et je
suis venu en me disant je ne vais rien
dire et vous voyez bien que je
j'entendais j'entends cela et je vous
faire part d'un sentiment madame la
ministre avec beaucoup de sincérité
voyez-vous l'ena a été pensée préfigurée
par jean zay grand ministre de la
république comme l'ont montré des textes
récents de pascal ory et pierre alaux et
puis après la résistance elle a été
créée michel devrait etc
et il y a eu deux il y a une origine est
une vertu et une existence profondément
républicaines de l'ena et il ya une
chose que je ne comprends pas du tout
vous pouvez faire les réformes des
réformes
heureusement mais rien n'empêche de dire
on supprime le sigle et n'a rien de ce
que vous avez dit et de ce que j'ai vu
n'est compatible ni incompatible avec le
fait de garder une école nationale
d'administration
pourquoi votre si faute il n'aurait sûr
que c'est un scalp alors je n'ignore pas
toutes les critiques qui ont existé mais
notez bien que ceux qui furent les plus
critiques comme jean pierre chevènement
faudra en parler avec vous aujourd'hui
avait acquis dans l'université française
et à l'ena le sens critique qui permet
de n'avoir pas d'indulgence fusent à
l'égard de l'institution dont on aime
anne
donc pourquoi ne pas garder l'ena tout
en la modifiant
moi je vais vous parler d'une expérience
toute simple il se trouve que depuis
longtemps je ne sais pas je dois je sais
pas combien de prêcher j'ai vu dans mon
département depuis cape décennies à
faire un grand nombre combien j'étais
contact avec des ministres et directeurs
de ministères de hauts fonctionnaires de
toute nature dans beaucoup de fonctions
électives et autres et je dois vous dire
que finalement j'ai été très frappé par
la grande qualité de beaucoup de ces
personnes due à un gros travail il faut
entrer à l'ena d'abord c'est c'est
facile de critiquer c'est parfois plus
difficile de rentrer ensuite quand vous
avez trois stages en préfecture à
l'ambassade en entreprise c'est comme un
intéressant ensuite s'il faut augmenter
la part d'études de connaissances dans
tel ou tel domaine rien n'empêche de le
faire et je dois dire que vous pouvez
parler avec patrice gérard qui est
quelqu'un qui a fait des réformes qui a
évolué pouvait parler avec les élèves
qui sont les étudiants qui quittent qui
sont très très actifs dans ces domaines
et je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose
voyez vous même bon le président de la
république en est issu est pas le seul
président de la république en être ici
mais quelque chose d'un petit peu
étrange de vouloir supprimer une
appellation qui compte beaucoup dans
l'histoire de la république et vous
voyez je prends un exemple très simple
je n'ai déjà cité excusez moi mes chers
collègues vous prenez cette crise
sanitaire
bon moi j'étais content la création des
ars
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'on des
plumes peu à peu les préfets et les
rêver ce groupe a de la justice s'occupe
pas des finances doit d'éducation et
s'occupa de la sonde et man mais dans
les départements il ya un intérêt ce qui
est là vous savez les régionales
deux régions vont c'est très bien j'ai
rien contre les ars mais qu'est ce qui
fonctionne finalement scellé préfet les
préfets de région et de département
on est tous là tous sont à des
visioconférences et on voit bien que ça
marche
un préfet qui a eu diverses missions de
toutes natures et l'état tient grâce à
des prêts faits qui sont des gens de
haute culture eux
voilà donc je voulais dire cela non pas
madame la mission dire qu'il n'y a pas
de réforme mais ne vous acharnez port
sur cette histoire de france cela c'est
une partie de l'histoire de france l'ena
voilà et faites attention aussi parce
que je vois des articles les diplomates
qui disent bon on est un des pays au
monde où le qui tient c'est notre
culture on n'est pas un pays fédéral
on est un pays qui tient par une
certaine idée de l'état bon on tient
alors je ne dis pas qu'il faut rien
réformer un je suis pas du tout il
mobilise pas du tout pas du tout mais
cette culture de l'état je crois qu'elle
est consubstantiel et moi j'ai toujours
pensé je suis pour la décentralisation
mais c'est parce que je suis pour la
décentralisation que ceci pour un état
fort un état fort n'est pas un état
omnipotent ceva un état qui veut tout
faire
c'est un état qui fait ce qu'il a à
faire en termes de fonctions régaliennes
et aussi de solidarité parce que la
décentralisation c'est pas 500 un
égoïsme départementaux 34 mais l'égoïsme
communaux non l'état il doit faire la
péréquation il doit faire que ça marche
mais ça n'empêche pas la
décentralisation au contraire cela
conforte donc je voulais dire cela ça
n'apporte rien je suis persuadé je
finirai ma conclusion pour vous dire une
expérience voyez vous un de vos
prédécesseurs
heureusement vous êtes dans une
meilleure situation que lui parce que là
il a dû abandonner son mandat de maire
bon dans une circonstance avec moi il
est difficile de diriger une mairie dans
certaines circonstances toujours est il
qu'il s'était occupé de ce sujet et il
nous avait réunis selon avec j'étais
allé au nom de la commission des lois
avec catherine tasca à une réunion est
préalablement j'étais allé voir le cher
jean pierre jouyet alors il m'avait dit
c'est fait formidable le on va pas les
gens ils vont pas rentrer comme ça
conseillers d'état des grands corps à la
la alors bon
donc si libre écoute très bien qui va
m'expliquer comment ton système 20
marché et alors il a expliqué alors
d'abord chaque administration
chaque grand corps fera des fiches pour
voir les besoins les attentes
et puis chaque candidat sera des fiches
pour dire ses desiderata et veillera une
première entretien puis un deuxième
entretien puis on essaiera de btan
rapport les fiches avec les desiderata
et puis je lui ai dit arrête ce système
là ça va créer les fils d'archevêque
mais si c'était tellement compliqué et
il y avait tellement on revenez à la
connivence est justement ce que l'ena
apporter c'est d'arrêter avec la
connivence et par conséquent je pense et
je rejoins ce qu'a dit prix bas et sur
la l'entrée je suis d'accord que on
rentre pas au conseil d'état comme
auditeur que contre temps on ait eu
l'occasion d'aller voir ce que c'est
qu'une direction des affaires sociales
une soupe récuse très bien mais que
quand on arrive il y ait des procédures
hyper rigoureuse parce que tous ces
machins là où de fil en aiguille savard
créée justement ce contre quoi avait
prémunit l'idée du concours après tout
qui est une idée républicaine
même si je suis partisan qu'on fasse
tout pour que les jeunes des quartiers
défavorisés puissent accéder à ce
concours mais voilà non excusez moi
merci
pardonne-moi enchère président mais je
suis trop bavard mais à ce moment là
le pardon est consubstantiel mais 2030
ça tient pas mais j'en tire la
conclusion que la démonstration elle
voulait le propos étaient tenus pour
faire une démonstration à d'autres fins
c'est une démonstration assez faciles à
faire mon pardon tu es tu as mon pardon
bien évidemment mais madame la ministre
a déjà beaucoup répandu en début de
séance mais je lui rende la parole
d'allah belrhiti j'ai bien compris elles
sont notées au plumitif de madame la
ministre je vais être beaucoup plus
courte
c'est sûr mais je vous rejoins je pense
que votre réforme est là effectivement
va apporter une certaine modernisation
de l'ena mais je crois qu'on aurait pu
garder le terme d na qui est très
important parce que c'est vrai que l'ena
jouit d'une excellente réputation au
niveau international j'aimerais réagir
sur une contradiction dans ce que vous
dites
entre vous parler à la fois de
méritocratie et en même temps vous nous
dit on va réserver 35 place aux élèves
boursiers
moi ça m'inquiète parce que je crois que
les deux ne vont pas de pair c'est une
école qui effectivement doit être dédiée
au mérite au travail et je pense que
réserver des places à certains élèves
personnellement je n'y vois pas de
mérite merci merci madame la ministre
vous avez la parole
alors
[Musique]
monsieur le sénateur sûr que je
rencontre régulièrement quand je me
rends dans le loiret et je le ferai le
lien avec votre question sur les classes
préparatoires du talent du service
public puisqu'il y en a à orléans
emma 74 en france et je pense est
important de bien comprendre la
mécanique puisque nous ne sommes pas
dans une logique de discrimination
positive apportée d'un autre modèle que
les autres je conteste pas votre
diagnostic sûr d'abord ce qu'a apporté
l'ena à la france de ce qu elle a aussi
créé dans notre histoire de ce qu'ont
apporté ce qu'est la forme et dans
d'autres pays
et comme je le dis en préalable rien de
ce que je dis est ce que nous portons
n'est contre des hommes ou des femmes
c'est un système c'est une organisation
qui nous faut regarder avec lucidité
voire nos forces et nos faiblesses
capable de faire évoluer les choses qui
ont besoin de l'être mais quand vous
dites
évidemment que j'ai rencontré j'écoutais
les anciens élèves les élèves les cadres
cm2 critique qui ressorte et qui font le
lien avec ce que vous avez cités dans
votre conclusion
d'abord les na est devenue ou a été de
plus en plus au fond une institution de
classement puisque vous ne choisissiez
pas un poste vous étiez recruté pour
vous l'ensemble de votre carrière
mon accord et l'ensemble des élèves je
crois que j'ai pu rencontrer m'ont tous
dit unanimement que cette pression du
classement qui définit toute votre vie
au fond créé avec un assentiment au sein
de l'institution qui était très
dommageable
j'observe que ce classement a quand même
amené à des par le temps à cette nombre
d'allocations de nos ressources qui sont
contraires je crois aux intérêts de
l'état
il n'est pas normal qu'on ait dit à
beaucoup de jeunes que choisir de
commencer sa carrière au ministère de la
santé où les solidarités ou du travail
allez vous offrir allez vous offrez une
moins bonne carrière que si vous aviez
travaillé dans un corps d'inspection de
contrôle nous avons pris la décision dès
l'année 2000 21 de quasiment doubler le
nombre de postes de sortie aux mises à
ma santé et du travail qui ont vu de la
crise à la fois économique d'emploi et
sanitaires que nous devons vivre est un
minimum par rapport aux besoins de
l'état et donc je tiens à vous dire que
dans la réforme que nous proposons
nous gardons le
à 100 de sortie comme mécanisme
d'allocation des premiers postes parce
que là où je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est que c'est dans tous les systèmes
qui existent
le seul qui permet d'éviter les effets
de réseau de recommandations et donc de
reproduction sociale pour que
méritocratique mans l'implication que
les uns et les autres ont eu dans leur
scolarité leur permettent de choisir
leur premier poste mais leur premier
poste ne prévert terminera plus comme
c'était le cas aujourd'hui l'ensemble de
leur carrière
et puis vous avez dit je vous croyais un
état fort ça tombe bien moi aussi mais
il ya juste deux chiffres que j'aimerais
partager avec vous parce que je crois
qu'ils montrent bien au fond l'ampleur
du défi qui est devant nous aujourd'hui
90%
les fonctionnaires sont en dehors de la
petite couronne
mais 90% des cadres dirigeants des hauts
fonctionnaires sont à l'intérieur la
petite couronne de paris
un état fort pour moi et madame la
présidente la vessie docteur c'est quand
même un état qui est capable de
positionner ses compétences ses
ressources ses meilleurs éléments je
vais dire au plus près des enjeux et de
complexité difficulté et donc ça veut
dire ce faucon repenser complètement la
gestion des carrières la location des
parcours un malien au tour comment sa
carrière ont tour à tour suite et donc
je pense que l'état fort c'est pas juste
des évidemment il ya des institutions et
des principes il ya une histoire
mais ne faisons pas vous voyez d'un an
je tiens une part évidemment d'histoire
le centre de la réforme vous avez vu je
crois qu'elle va bien au delà madame la
sénatrice sur les concours talents et
les classes préparatoires talent du
service public le constat initial tu
sais qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une
immense majorité de la jeunesse qui
parce qu'elle est à l'université et
qu'elle vient soit d'un village rural
soit d'une famille plus modestes soit
d'un quartier priante à la ville vous
dise des jeunes très méritant excellent
motivés qui aimerait ça dans leur pays
mais qu'ils ont eux-mêmes arrêté d'avoir
cette idée parce qu'ils vous disent les
yeux dans les yeux que ce n'est pas pour
eux et donc le principal enjeu pour nous
c'est pas la discrimination c'est
l'autocensure
comment nous redonnons à des jeunes
méritants bryant qui pour des études
difficiles à l'université dans des
masters
l'alternance de droit des collectivités
dans des master de droit public dans des
licences les bonnes conditions pour se
préparer aux concours parce que je tiens
à le dire les places que vous citez sont
ouvertes à l'issue du même concours du
même jour des mêmes épreuves est donc
l'enjeu de notre procédure c'est que
1700 jeunes puissent se préparer dans
d'excellentes conditions de soutien
financier 4000 euros de bourse
supplémentaire par an de tutorat
renforcé parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui vous permet de réussir un
concours qui s'apprennent pas dans les
livres d'un diplôme parce que dans
beaucoup de familles modestes une année
de classe préparatoire c'est une année
blanche parce qu on part du principe que
le compensera pas réussi et donc
pourquoi dédiée du temps un concours si
on ne réussit pas un accès favorisé au
logement étudiant pour que des jeunes
boursiers de nos 74 universités lieu de
formation universitaire se prépare dans
de bonnes conditions à réussir ces
concours et à s'y inscrire on a ouvert
ses ses 15 % de places en plus aux
concours externes pour cinq écoles et
six concours apartheid à rentrer
pourquoi cela pas toutes les écoles les
services publics donc les nas et cinq ou
six élèves
lynette ces cinq ou six ans on est sûrs
et des toutes petites cohortes pourquoi
c'est également parce que c'est celle on
observe un plus grand niveau
d'autocensure
ce sont les écoles on voit bien que
entre ceux qui préparent les concours à
la haute fonction publique et ceux qui
s'inscrivent ils réussissent très bien
plat ou trop court mais il ya un frein
de perception un frein de d'autocensure
beaucoup de sociologues ont décrit ces
mécanismes qui fait qu'il n'ya pas
l'assentiment contre là où ils sont et
sept projets qu'ils pourraient avoir
pour eux mêmes il ya un chemin possible
c'est une voie que nous ouvrons de
manière expérimentale pour trois ans je
tiens à vous dire que mon ambition c'est
que la qualité du recrutement de la
motivation de l'accompagnement que nous
donnerons à ces jeunes dans les classes
talons du service public suffisant
quelques années à résoudre ce brain
l'autocensure et d'ailleurs les élèves
de ces classes sont tout à fait l'egypte
à se présenter aux concours externes
et d'ailleurs si son et je pense pour
tout vous dire que nous aurons largement
le niveau et que donc le sujet n'est pas
le niveau
le sujet et la capacité pour eux de
penser que c'est crédible de s'inscrire
je pense que une réforme réussie c'est
que d'oran peut-être trois ans peut-être
six ans je sais pas mais non
raisonnable et plus besoin de dire que
c'est une voie dédiée et parce qu'on
aura réussi au fond à sortir d'un
déterminisme aujourd'hui qui est quand
même mon avis très anti républicain en
fait c'est qu'aujourd'hui si vous
n'allez pas rue saint-guillaume ou place
du panthéon vos chances d'intégrer ces
écoles sont très très faible et je pense
qu'il est nulle part écrit voyez dans le
contrat républicain qu'il faut
impérativement aller quelques années à
paris pour devenir un serviteur de
l'intérêt général et donc remettre voyez
à valenciennes à brest à limoges à
clermont ferrand âge des classes de
préparation aux concours de la fonction
publique
notre bonne condition c'est pour moi
essentiel parce que sinon ça veut dire
que c'est la promesse républicaine qui
devient complètement
enfin pour beaucoup de jeunes une
illusion pour d'autres et ça crée du
séparatisme est sacrée du ressentiment
est sacré la sortie le sentiment que la
promesse républicaine elle et pour
d'autres états pour eux donc c'est ça
mon combat est donc si vous passez les
mêmes épreuves c'est le même jour c'est
donc le même jury on ne sont pas les
places sur dossier et d'ailleurs ou
préparent ces jeunes avant tout après à
passer les concours parce qu'on croit au
concours pour cela de méritocratique et
points supplémentaires importants il y
aura qu'une liste d'admissibles et
qu'une liste des admis donc ce sera
parole à fab éthique sans distinction
savoir si vous êtes là parce que on vous
la famille le petit coup de pouce pour
que vous allez vous inscrire au concours
ou si vous êtes là parce que je serais
aussi un concours est moindre à passer
moi même juriste qui à mon avis est un
gage aussi de la regard transverses
uniforme
merci madame pas d'autres questions
il me reste à vous remercier renault
mise pour les propos les précisions que
vous avez apporté à la commission et je
vais donc levé la séance
merci
[Musique]